there's many people who have inspired me
during my career when I grew up I was
probably most inspired by some of the
teachers who I most admired like music
teachers for example not science
teachers I'm afraid I greatly admire and
was tremendously influenced as a role
model if you like by my mentors drew
goldstein at Mike Brown who were my my
mentors in my postdoctoral training and
who our Nobel laureates I think I've
always admired people who have had the
ability to actually make discoveries
that allow us to understand something
and not only to discover and you
approach a new technique and I see this
with brawn and goldstein I can also see
that for example in the work that bears
akhmin did after he won the Nobel Prize
which she won is you probably know for
patch clamping but afterwards he became
a tool while he was actually he he
developed neuroscience in a way that I
found really inspiring and so those are
people I I could mention